hello everyone and welcome to a bit of a
different format than what you're used
to usually I would just uh you know show
you the moves talk about the players a
little bit to talk about the events they
are playing and maybe we show
um some engine lines maybe we talk about
what the great players of the past
thought about the position and it you
know it's a it's a nice story definitely
but I already made 3 000 videos like
3182 videos pretty much in the exact
same format so I thought it's uh it's
time to uh leave that behind and start a
new chapter of the channel and from now
on I will only be discussing games using
nothing but storytelling uh and poetry
uh so the first game I decided to show
you is Adolf Anderson versus Jean
Dufresne it's a famous famous game I was
played in Berlin in 1852 it's called The
Evergreen game I'm sure you guys know
why might have even shown it on the
channel maybe once or twice can't really
remember but it's it's a really a
wonderful game and I don't think it was
ever discussed quite in this fashion so
let's uh let's check it out and this is
how it goes once upon a time in a realm
where Knights and Bishops reigned two
Grandmaster Smith for a legendary duel
the battlefield was a checkered board
and the heroes were the formidable out
of Anderson and the brilliant Jean
Dufresne the game unfolded like a dance
a ballet of wooden pieces moving in
Harmony in the opening the pawns
Advanced cautiously forming lines of
defense and Paving the way for the
Nobles Knight sleep like gazelles their
leaps tracing L-shaped patterns in the
air Bishop's glided diagonally slicing
through the battlefield with unwavering
precision as the game progressed the
grand Masters exchanged pieces in a
delicate Waltz each seeking to outwit
the other the Queen's powerful and
Majestic stalked the board striking fear
in their adversaries their potential for
Destruction was unparalleled yet their
presence was as fleeting as a comet's
Tale in a daring sacrifice Anderson
offered his Queen to the hungry jaws of
the French pieces the grand Masters
locked eyes their brows furrowed with
intensity as the Queens fell the
sacrifice are calculated ruse opened the
gates for Anderson's rook and Bishop to
storm the enemy's Fortress capturing
their first precious Monarch the finale
approached like a gathering storm with
the Evergreen scent of victory in the
air Anderson's pieces swirled around the
board in a dizzying dance cornering the
French King in a suffocating embrace the
Checkmate was a crescendo thus the the
Checkmate was a crescendo a culmination
of a symphony of moves orchestrated to
Perfection thus the Evergreen game was
etched into the analysis of History a
poetic testimony to the beauty of Chess
and the Art of sacrifice the grand
Masters dance was immortalized The
Echoes of their wooden footsteps forever
resonating on the checkered stage
the end